إنه منفذ جيد، إنه أمر جيد
التركيز على
مالوري كريستوفرسون، خريجة جامعة ولاية ميشيغان الحديثة، التي
تذهب إلى متجر خيوط فنية منسوجة لشراء مستلزمات الكروشيه الخاصة بها،
إنه جزء كبير من حياتي، لذا في أي مكان
من رسم اللوحة والحياكة
مهما كان ما تقوله فإن الحرف اليدوية
تساعد  تركيزها على شيء إيجابي هو
وسيلة للبقاء مشغولة مع عدم خلق
ضغوط إضافية. أعتقد أنه من السهل على
الناس أن يشعروا بالحزن لأنه ليس هناك الكثير
للقيام به. صن ميد كروفت هي
صاحبة متجر خيوط فنية منسوجة في شرق
لانسينغ، وهي ليست غريبة عليها
فوائد الصياغة هناك العديد من
الأوراق الأكاديمية الموجودة حول
فوائد الحياكة والحياكة للتوتر والقلق
منذ أن
أعلنت عن دروس الحياكة والكروشيه المجانية لطلاب جامعة
ولاية ميشيغان وموظفيها،
وقد تبرعت شركة Knitters بوقتها، وقد تبرعت
الشركات في جميع أنحاء العالم  من خلال
التبرع بإمداداتهم، كانت الاستجابة
هائلة حقًا، ونعم، إنه أمر يثلج
الصدر بشكل لا يصدق
وأعتقد أنه يتحدث عن
مدى شعور الأشخاص اليائسين
تجاه هذا الأمر، وقد سجل ما يقرب من 200 طالب
حتى الآن وتطوع 90 شخصًا
لتدريس الفصول التي
يأملونها  للحفاظ على استمرار البرنامج حتى
نهاية هذا الصيف، فإن
الشيء الأكثر إيلامًا هو عدم القدرة على المساعدة،
لذا فإن
القدرة على القيام بشيء ما أمر
جيد حقًا، ومن
الجيد حقًا
إنشاءه